le cabriolet de collection n'est plus
qu'un amas de tôle calcinée dans ce
hangar qui servait à un particulier pour
restaurer des voitures tout a brûlé dans
la nuit de lundi à mardi
certainement un geste criminel pour les
enquêteurs
le propriétaire de la grange brûlé
habite paris
c'est un adjoint de la commune qui
parlent pour lui qu'ils tournent non
parce que maintenant le tacle on attend
que les on attaque les particuliers mais
la personne qui est son garage quel
boulet c'est comme elles sont 100 gagne
pain donc là la saisir de plus en plus
grave alors est il tout rapprochait fois
pourquoi la pompe à essence
la pompe à essence en plus du seul
commerce de dampierre ces mariages qui
les tient avec sa salariée depuis la
série d' incendies la patronne se pose
des questions à n'en plus dormir la nuit
on dort pas depuis à chaque fois d'un
dès qu'on entend être à venir du matin
les sirènes d'un netbook
on comprend sa toupie rien puis voilà on
vit pas dans mon commerce avec des
pompes à essence de bouteilles de gaz
comme et font voler les voitures on
pense ça peut être nous demain donc
voila depuis le 18 février dernier
dampierre sous brou y comptabilise cinq
incendies le ou les incendiaires se sont
même acharné par deux fois sur l'atelier
municipal
deux autres incendies ont eu lieu sur la
commune voisine de saint amand en
puisaye un container à poubelles et une
voiture réduite à l'état d'épave
ça devient dangereux et inquiétant quoi
il ya un monsieur qui viennent me dire
j'ai quitté la région parisienne parce
que
il y avait plein de choses qui s'y
passait et puis voilà que ça arrive ici
l' enquête de gendarmerie suit son cours
des patrouilles sont organisées la nuit
la puiser en tout cas attend vite
la fin du cauchemar